this is Christmas  your lovely Christmas go put on one of  my ties we're going to midnight mass not  a tractor auction  apparently circle believes that he's a  pointy century night  Nicole Christopher Frederick lines of  Norwich and you service me oh boy you  call yourselves Carroll Arts  this year it's gonna be Christmas in  Africa I'm in this place surrounded by  wild animals in New York oh you're gonna  add the secret ingredient we're fighting  for ten thousand dollars yeah I want to  give the judges something to WoW about  what can go wrong there's a lot of stuff  happening and it's all bad I'm not gonna  kill you guys I promise  thank you tell her that you like her  notice how spiders always thought it  easy you just have to tell her you want  the same relationship plus boning not  any Christmas gift you too can match oh  my god my heart can't take how much I  love you right now  [Music]  it's beginning to look a lot like  Netflix  [Music]  you